[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8
loisirs toutes vos idées sorties dans le
département on commence tout de suite
avec le sommaire de ce numéro
pendant les vacances ça prenait la
cuisine en anglais avec terry belton
américaine installée à versailles elle
donne des cours
petits et grands dans sa langue
d'origine elle sera avec nous au plateau
pour nous en dire plus le centre alfred
devenu de voisins-le-bretonneux propose
des stages pour les vacances poterie
informatique vous science l'équipe vous
donne l'embarras du choix
nous avons suivi l'un de ces ateliers
est bientôt pâques et la célèbre chasse
aux oeufs et par endroit les cloches ont
pris un peu d'avancé 7 à rambouillet que
mélanie nous emmènera pour notre
rendez-vous junior comme chaque semaine
le parc du château abrite déjà quelques
surprises et les beaux jours ont sorti
les fontaines de versailles de leur
sommeil hivernal dans le parc du château
c'est le moment de venir admirer les
grandes eaux musicales 55 fontaine sont
à découvrir l'occasion de se promener au
rythme de la musique
une virée à travers les jardins à la
française imaginé par andré le nôtre à
la demande du roi louis xiv on écoute le
directeur des spectacles du château de
versailles propos recueillis par nicolas
kirillovitch c'est très facile d'accès
en tout cas dans la tête on a pas de
barrière de visite pour un jardin et je
crois que ça compte
et puis bien sûr il ya aussi des
aficionados combien pour d'eau beaucoup
de domaines qui sont des gens qui vont
venir régulièrement voir ce jardin parce
qu'il en soit amoureux voir ses
fontaines c'est une des salles de plus
du château le château de versailles il
ya de l'intérieur il ya de l'extérieur
traités avec le même soin et peut-être à
l'époque avec le même budget tellement
les fontaines coûter cher
et on reste à versailles mais pour
parler cuisine cette fois et pas
n'importe laquelle en anglais avec nous
terry molton la créatrice de let's cook
in english
elle est américaine installée dans la
cité royale et anime des ateliers pour
cuisiner dans la langue de shakespeare
bonjour thierry mauger alors tout
d'abord expliqué nous ces ateliers
comment ça se déroule combien de temps
ça dure qui s'adresse d'accord il ya des
ateliers chaque semaine dans les
vacances scolaires et aussi quand les on
prend pas un accord il ya des des cours
le mercredi après midi de samedi après
midi et c'est vraiment pour tout âge à
partir de 3 ans les tout petit bien avec
le père les enfants en primaire collège
j'ai des parents des conquérants qui
viennent et marraines karen soit en
famille soit que les enfants ensemble
est scellé tout petit groupe de six
enfants
six élèves et des îles travaillent
ensemble de parts de faire la recette a
à z
donc je pense qu'un anglais en se muant
c'est très ludique aux messins cours
d'anglais cours de cuisine ensemble en
même temps tous les galas et j'ai un
tableau avec le vocabulaire
après avoir fait les recettes qu'on va
lire le 20 septembre semble je vais
corriger les prononciations chez les
nouveau vocabulaire ils ont appris le
jour là et vous le disiez justement des
trois ans alors ça s'adresse vraiment
aidé le lait 1er âge en fait on peut
participer quel que soit son niveau mais
j'ai pas mal de demandes pour les
tout-petits donc j'ai créé les cours
exprès pour parents et enfants niveau
maternelle dans chaque mois il ya en
cours le samedi après midi à 16 heures
pour les tout petits
est ce que pour vous pouvez nous donner
des exemples de recettes qu'est ce que
pour les tout petits jeux dans les cours
de cuisine marines aux mails plupart du
temps ces sucres et des cookies des
marines des boîtes américaines
mais aussi ses fruits sucrés tex-mex
créole une patte les agne comme cette
semaine c'est sûrement le dernier au
saumon et épinards donc j'ai vraiment un
petit peu tout et vous le disiez vous
parliez de cette semaine justement
pendant les vacances scolaires ou et qui
continue la semaine prochaine vous
proposer des stages également tous les
jours wild eyes et des enfants qui
s'inscrit pour deux semaines
ça peut être à la carte très bien et du
coup l'anglais est ce que c'est une
langue plutôt facile à apprendre pour
les enfants moi je crois oui et se tuent
le plus jeune c'est plus facile que le
français c'est vrai qu'on dit souvent et
comment vous est venue l'idée de lancer
ces ateliers comment est ce qu'un jour
vous êtes dit je suis je suis artiste
j'aime les choses créatives et j'aime
enseigner et j'ai déjà donné des cours
d'anglais aux enfants et ça arrive des
fois de donner des cours d'anglais elle
coule de tremblay cours de cuisine et il
était vraiment content pour jour que je
dis ok dans les cuisines on va faire des
cookies des machines
donc un jour je voulais vraiment créer
mon propre business avec des statuts
entre entrepreneurs et donc c'était
facile pour moi de juste pensé late
booking déchets dans les cours j'ai
commencé et même pour les adultes et
après j'ai fait des cours pour les
enfants et maintenant j'ai plus de
demandes pour les enfants mais il ya des
familles qui aiment bien venir
l'ensemble une activité familiale et
donc ça fait sept ans que vous proposez
ces ateliers et même si la cuisine se
fait en anglais les produits utilisés
eux sont bien français et surtout locaux
oui comme on les cas liés à versailles
j'ai essayé vraiment acheter local dans
les commerçants tout près de mon atelier
pasteur sa place de marché
et des produits frais le jour même et
vous commencez un petit peu également le
avec l'objet oui oui je pense à ça
surtout quand j'ai des citrons et les
orges pour les est je rentre vraiment
dans les magasins bio parce que
maintenant on trouve au moins trois
boutiques bio à versailles avant avec
une l'outil est donc c'est plus facile à
acheter
et pour un bon prix c'est plus
accessible et pour finir leur en dehors
des stages vous proposer d'autres
formulent également alors qu'est ce que
c'est on peut privatiser également les
cours oui oui j'ai beaucoup de demandes
cette année pour les anniversaires les
garçons les filles je ne peux nager
aussi des familles qui viennent ou des
amis qui viennent ça peut réveiller des
mamans avec des enfants ensemble où les
couples ça peut être pour un
anniversaire ou juste pour être ensemble
pour s'amuser en deuil
alors ça pour réserver c'est plutôt les
week-ends c'est vraiment les samedi et
dimanche c'est ça oui pour les cours
privés samedi ou dimanche après midi à
15 heures les cours sont une 45 minutes
donc on commence pour regarder tous les
ingrédients sur la table après on va
atteindre 7 à az
après on va aller vers cet ensemble et
est plein des dégustations et rentrer à
la maison et va casser il peut partager
avec la famille et on repart avec ses
créations très bien merci beaucoup en
tout cas terry d'être venu sur notre
plateau pour nous parler de vos ateliers
de cuisine en anglais donc à noter pour
les enfants des stages proposés tous les
jours la semaine prochaine et les
week-ends le reste de l'année merci
terry bolton merci mme camille et les
vacances c'est aussi au centre alfred de
vigny de voisins-le-bretonneux des
stages sont proposés toute la semaine
prochaine poterie informatique ou
science c'est le moment de s'inscrire
et cette semaine nous avons suivi
l'atelier des savants fous les enfants
ont joué les experts saint quentin en
yvelines
regardez qu'est ce qui a bien pu
et retrouvé mort sur le lieu du crime un
gâteau au chocolat un chat et du poison
c'est parti pour relever les empreintes
et trouver quel poudre est toxique
tout était devenue marron et ça faisait
des espèces de
peut-il lui loue des choses dans le
genre c'était pas très un petit peu
bizarre
les autres habitués des habitudes plus
allez voir que cette réaction t'as
jamais vue des exercices pour leur
apprendre les sciences mais aussi
arraisonné et des du professeur
garnoulles ses enfants maintenant quête
pour retrouver le coupable grâce aux
analyses médico légales
pendant une semaine on fait un stage
scientifique donc tous les jours on a un
atelier sur un thème différent donc
aujourd'hui c'était sur la police
scientifique la science médico légal et
deviennent des experts ils sont mises en
situation voilà on essaie de de créer un
petit imaginaire au siec des petites
enquêtes qui ne vient pas ce que vous
faisiez plusieurs choses on faisait pas
les mêmes choses pas pareil donc à 7m
bien malgré les apparences ce n'est pas
le chat le coupable
résultat après investigations le
chocolat est toxique pour les chiens
pendant les vacances le centre alfred de
vigny propose d'autres stages pour
devenir potier ou créer son propre jeu
vidéo
mélanie nous a rejoint au plateau est
aujourd'hui va nous parler d'un
rendez-vous junior pour les gourmands
bonjour mélanie bonjour camille en tout
cas pour les fans de chocolat faut aimer
on sait jamais mais c'est tout
simplement parce que dans un peu plus
d'une semaine ce sera pâques les cloches
vont passer et sonner le lundi 17 avril
elles sont même en avance dans certains
endroits comme à rambouillet alors avec
les vacances les cloches ont déjà caché
des oeufs dans les jardins du château et
pourrait militer leur chocolat il faut
faire preuve de connaissances et recruté
il ya un petit plan et des énigmes
ils partent dans les jardins à la
recherche d'offres en carton à ces
grands qui leur permettent de répondre à
des questions et une fois qu'ils ont
répondu à toutes ses questions ils
reviennent à la boutique du château et
s'ils ont trouvé la bonne réponse on
leur offre un petit sachet de francs
chocolat alors le plan est disponible à
l'entrée du château l'activité coûte 7
euros 50 et en plus de la chasse les
enfants de 3 à 12 ans peuvent faire un
atelier manuel en fonction des âges
alors ils peuvent créer un lapin avec
des bandes de papier qui vont colorer ou
réaliser là aussi un masque de lapin ou
bien les histoires
alors attention ces animations ne sont
pas disponibles les week-ends et toutes
les informations sont à retrouver sur le
site internet du château qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran
et si les informations sont bonnes mais
l'ani les cloches ne devrait pas tarder
à passer à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
aussi aux informations sont bonnes qui
risque c'est un petit lapin qui vous les
a donnés mais a peut-être en allant au
château j'étais pas loin de la bergerie
nationale donc du coup peut-être dans la
première ça sera à l'honneur samedi
prochain le 15 avril dans le parc de
l'après vandry il y aura plus de 1400 à
retrouver et parmi ces 1400 de quatre
seront en or et ça permettra de
remporter un oeuf géant chocolat une
autre chasse aux yeux camille à voisins
le bretonneux cette fois le lundi 17
avril le rendez vous est donné au parc
de la croix de bois à partir de 16h je
pense que là il ya de quoi satisfaire
tous les gourmands et oui du chocolat
partout et sous toutes ses formes et à
consommer avec modération bien sûr merci
mes lignes entre que de nous avoir parlé
de ces rendez vous on termine avec
l'agenda avec une dernière date à noter
jusqu'au 11 avril les salles de cinéma
font la part belle aux classiques du
septième art le festival play it again
propose de re découvrir aux petits
cinémas en version restaurée
parmi les salles yvelinoise le grenier à
sel de trappes diffusera dimanche 9
avril alice comédie the walt disney et
indochine de régis wargnier et on se
quitte en musique sur les images de la
bande-annonce du festival le justement
je vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour
un nouveau numéro
je vous souhaite de très bonnes vacances
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]